there is this turbulent storm a brewing
and going down on Vanderpump Rules yes
so we got to talk some scandalf first
yeah you know we figured we got to Spill
the tea this morning this is a
full-blown love affair I wish we both
would have tried harder you don't
deserve one Frontier of mine where were
you when you first heard about the news
breaking with skandival how did you find
out my buddy actually texted me Jason
yeah my buddy Jason texted me he's like
hey he's like you were right all along
and that's all he texted me he's like
you were right all along I woke up the
idea I was like what so I was like what
are you talking I thought he's mad at me
I was like did I do something wrong so
text him he's like no did you see them
you wake up this morning you read
anything I go on any tabloid or whatever
I'm like no as soon as I we literally
just woke up and look and I'm like we
both lost each other I'd be like are you
reading this are you seeing this no it
just went all downhill from there yeah
so you we're in our living room
yes yeah yeah and like the day before we
were actually at the aquarium I got I
just got a message from Andy he's like
hey do you want to come on watch Happens
Live and I was like yeah sure and then
this happened and then he's like we're
gonna move you just because you know one
of the first ones to be at Washington's
live right after this whole thing broke
out yeah
this thing was one after another after
that yeah it's just like more and more
details coming out wow so when your
buddy said you were right all along you
predicted this I mean I don't want to
say I predicted it but I predicted it
okay how so Jack I'm just not surprised
I'm just not surprised honestly with
that I think it's surprising that it was
them too for sure yeah I mean you know
he's done this before I just thought
they were like good friends yeah this is
not his first he's waiting because on
the show like he brought up this like
Miami girl thing but this is before my
time yeah but and nobody believed it
that he had cheated with his girl from
Miami so that's what he's saying like so
everyone's like you were right you were
right that's why they're like you were
right right yeah because nobody would
believe him before I was like I'm like
everybody so here's the thing when I was
on the show everybody would hide behind
me like they would just you were there I
was the villain but Jax you also brought
it upon yourself
not trying to justify it at all I was
but everybody could kind of slide
through and get away with things now
can't hide behind me anymore so now all
the demons are coming to the surface
well and some of your own demons are
coming to the surface too because now
people are making the comparison to what
happened between you and Chris and Dodie
years ago do you think that's a fair
comparison no because he was cheating on
her at the time and I wasn't I was
single
yeah and also he's been with Ariana for
like yes almost 10 years and you know
best friends with Raquel so it's like he
this was this is like a whole on
relationship this isn't just a hooked up
with somebody in this and I'm sorry to
go back this is a relationship there's
lack of empathy there that's what
bothers me with him and the like the
premeditation of it all that's the scary
part like this has been going on this
was like to me I'm not justifying at all
like like I said but when you hook up
with somebody like a hook up and you get
mad like oh why did I do that and then
this has been going on and they share a
house together you know yeah it's just a
lot that goes in I mean this is going to
get messy before it gets better yeah I
think it's already yeah it is explosive
it's a very messy situation and have you
seen the mid-season trailer that one's
explosive I'm sure I mean they picked
right back up after all this happened I
mean of course well I think you have to
you know I mean it is absolutely
explosive you want anything for you to
die
she's just feeling like I can only
imagine how angry she is yeah I can only
imagine she deserves to have fun right
now like she needs to I Know It's
upsetting her but I feel like this is
going to be her breakout you know like
she's gonna she's gonna move on from
this get rid of this situation she has
with him and move on and and shine and
be who she truly probably wants to be
yeah but where does the group go from
from Ian Sandoval and Raquel still
I have no idea how that's supposed to I
mean and like Shayna I know she feels
like she's lost two of her best friends
because like Sandoval and Raquel were so
close to her so now she's lost two of
her closest friends well I think
Sandoval kind of it's a shift that's for
sure never had control of Ariana she's a
very strong independent woman and I feel
like he couldn't control her and he
could control Raquel very easily she's
very easily manipulated she's the
definition of codependency she saw the
both of you at the Avenue you don't know
what's going on between us I don't
regret relationship so after you learned
in the news who's the first person you
called or texted I texted Sheena in law
first thing and we have a group chat and
I was like is this true and they just
wrote back yes like all cap and then I
was like oh my God how is Ariana because
having to go through this so publicly is
so mortifying like not to compare things
again but I like having to live this
publicly and then like being so
embarrassed by it and like having to go
through it like I just feel so bad for
Ariana having to go through this so
publicly have you talked to Ariana I've
checked in on Ariana a couple times I
haven't got to see her yet but um
definitely checked in on her and you
know just trying to be there for her as
much as I can I know that she hasn't
been alone for a second so that's the
good thing yeah exactly you need your
team yeah I think she's just super
shocked and I mean it's just terrible
and she I guess she said out of all the
guys I'm the only one that's checked in
with her me out of all people she was
like shocked she's like Jax Taylor is
the only guy who trucked reached in you
know checked up on me not even Schwartz
no neither of them did and Schwartz had
her as a best man at his wedding yeah a
groomsmen groomsmen unbelievable wow
isn't that something yeah that's crazy
have you talked to Sandoval have you
talked to Raquel talk to Schwartz last
time I saw Sandoval was what Labor Day
is that was that the party that we were
at yeah Orange County last time I saw
him was at Labor day we were at an event
in Orange County which is a couple hour
drive from our house and uh he was there
with Raquel yeah
there was a bunch of people there but we
just keep like like everyone else in the
world we're starting to be like wait
and it was just kind of like oh I just
didn't I didn't think about it I just so
interesting yeah it's crazy what message
would you have for Sandoval in the midst
of all of this drama that's going on
right now you know we all make mistakes
in life you know and we God knows I've
made my fair share I would just you know
just try to be a little humble humble
like I think it's gone to his head a
little bit the the nine Person cover
band and the little bar in a strip mall
like that's getting to his head a little
bit he's got to like come down to earth
and realize what he's done again coming
from me it doesn't mean a lot but look
at Ariana she stood by you brother you
guys are right for each other or not she
stood by you for how many years she's
put up all with a lot I've seen what's
going on behind closed doors with people
who don't see she's put up with a lot
he's not the easiest person to be around
it's just one of those things just keep
your mouth shut and just do as you're
told like that's probably the best keep
your mouth shut and do as you're told he
would have taken his own
and I've come a long way since that time
of my life I'm such a different person
now so I do can reflect a little bit be
like man I wish I would have done that
so yeah my best advice is when I was
down where he was right now I've been
where he is it's an awful awful place
and it's just you just gotta you gotta
weather this storm and just learn from
it learn from it you gotta learn from it
and just show some empathy though you
just gotta show he didn't there's no
apology like at all and at most she
probably wouldn't have accepted by the
way now but now it's how long ago for
how many days past you should have said
it from the start
you know it's person number one yeah
exactly and I don't have a PRP exactly
the fan yes you should have picked up
the phone and called her not had some
crisis PR team write up some statement
and put it on social media we all know
he didn't write that so it's you got to
put that aside for a minute put the show
aside and take her feelings into that's
what I would have done so would you guys
come back to the show do you want to get
back into the mix of the show now that
this is
oh no no no no but we have things that
are coming arise I don't know what we're
allowed to talk they're working on it
we're working on situations yeah ideally
yeah I mean we would like to have is the
parents kind of on I'm sorry I've been
talking about the parents on one and
that's what I wanted to thank you but I
don't know it's all working worked out
it's just so this is causing a lot right
now so they're kind of waiting to see
how this plays out yeah but yeah I would
come back yes to answer your question
yes so you would come back to vaderpump
rules but I feel like you guys want to
get back into the mix of reality
television yes okay yeah so that's safe
to say that you would like to go back
into reality television we're going to
tread lightly when we do it definitely
but um yeah we're eager to get back it
was reported that you shot a show House
the villains yeah is that true how'd
that go
not yet but you did it you shot it yes
okay awesome so what are we expecting to
see it I don't know they don't tell me
okay so you will be a part of House of
Villains he will definitely be back on
TV what do you miss most about being on
reality television it sounds like you're
going to be able to scratch that itch
soon but what have you missed about
being on it the good times like you know
just going to traveling you know go
coming to New York and do stuff like
this like yeah this stuff I took for
granted for 10 years yeah I would
complain and and about it but I
was like I missed doing this we had a
lot of hard times on the show but we
also got married like we had some really
amazing moments so yeah our life was all
shared yeah all of our you know so all
that was really fun I do miss those
times you guys are teaming up to do a
podcast together so how did this come
about some folks will say wait the
timing is a little suspect because are
they writing the Scandal oh Lord no it's
been in the works for like a whole year
so yeah we teamed up with podcast one
and yeah just getting everything
together and we knew it was going to
come out March 28th is going to be our
first episode episode and this just
happened just just happened to you know
get like crazy and like all the media
attention and everything from it you
know we're gonna have guests on we're
gonna talk parenting we're gonna talk
obviously being on reality TV
I want to talk to other villains on
reality TV I want to we just talk about
a little bit of everything yes a little
bit of everything and make it before we
met after we met and stuff yeah talk
about reality TV yeah you know what's
real it's not secret stuff yeah
[Music]
foreign